so the tournament is now over
earlier uh about an hour ago i finished
my final round game
uh round nine against vibhov
route from india
and it was a fun final round uh let's
get into it i woke up this morning and i
wanted to go back to sleep but it was a
10 a.m round
so i couldn't really sleep in
and i decided to stick with my main
rapper tour
played the london opening
and i did a little bit of preparation
last night
i was actually preparing a really really
cool crazy line
that unfortunately we didn't go into but
i'll just share it just to give a sense
of
how
fun the prep could have been
as i saw my opponent uh plays this move
a lot online um
and like usually goes for queen's indian
setup
b6 on move two and i was going to play
knight c3
going into jobava london and after
bishop b7
i was actually preparing a novelty in
this position pawn h4
which is one of the top engine moves and
the idea is to get a very quick h5h6
but unfortunately we didn't go into this
and uh we actually went for
a way more standard variation
so have to save this for a future
opponent
but uh yeah after bishop f4 my opponent
played d5
and we actually got a line that
i like to play myself as black after
takes takes and bishop f5
this is a really solid reputable line
and
my opponent played this pretty quickly
so i assumed that he had prepared this
specifically for me
now the move i've been playing most
recently especially in online games is
bishop to b5 and this is considered to
be the most venomous move
um and there's a common trap here that a
lot of players fall into
uh if black just plays naturally e6
white can play knight e5 rook c8 and
then all of a sudden after takes takes
bishop a6 white is winning an exchange
now my opponent definitely would not
have gone into this
um but just to show let me share my um
my
online games
i've had this position 11 times
online and
i don't win every single time but
this is considered to already be very
good for white
so rather than
going for bishop to b5 i should explain
the reason why i didn't go over bishop
e5 is if black's repaired it can get
really messy like one of the main lines
is queen b6
and then something like c4 takes a4
and i was vaguely remembering some game
from the olympiad
i think it was fabiano carwana against
one of the players from uzbekistan
and fabiano actually lost as white in a
similar line where his opponent played
bishop d3
and the lines just weren't fresh in my
head so
i figured i would just avoid this line
entirely
and uh actually after the game my
opponent told me he had prepared exactly
what fabiano's opponent played against
him in olympia
so i think i made a decent choice
not going for the the sharper line but
going for a more
[Music]
solid positional line what happened to
the notation
uh
c3
yeah c3 was played
um
so c3 is
i think the most popular move and it's a
way that white's handled this position
for many many years
uh if you check out the games in
database
and after pawn e6 uh i decided to play
very solidly bishop to e2 now there is a
line here queen b3
which i would usually be happy to enter
from the black side there's a cool
gambit bishop d6
black sacrifices a pawn and then gets
this position
where
it's very very dangerous uh to play as
white especially if you're not prepared
and
i i would have more preparation here
from the black side so
i opted for bishop e2
and it leads to a
bit more quiet positional game but still
chances for white to play for some sort
of edge
even though it doesn't look too
impressive
we both complete development
and i play a very typical positional
move here upon a4
just discouraging any potential for
black's minority attack
and um yeah black wants to play a6 i can
maybe even play a5
and clamp down on the the queen side
so i was feeling good here um i barely
used any time off my clock and my
opponent was already taking time um
pretty early on
uh spent over 10 minutes to play rook
ac-8
and one of the things about this
position is it's not so easy to find a
plan for black like even though the
pieces are
pretty much fully optimized uh it's not
clear what to do next
and as white i i have a general sense of
what i'm doing i play bishop to f1
going for some knight e5 potential but
also just kind of waiting to see what
black is up to
uh he plays knight e4 now i play rook to
e3
and this is the typical move
some potential to rook lift later on and
get some king side attack
so we do trade knights takes and bishop
to e4
so opponents going for some
simplification
and here i just offer the trade of
bishops we trade
still very peaceful some more
liquidation now knight a5
and i do have to be careful of the
potential of knight b3
or knight c4
and in this position i played just kind
of preparatory move rook e2
ensuring that
the pawn is going to be defended and
knight c4 won't come
to attack the rook
uh it seems like i lost a little bit of
time moving the rook twice
but
in the grand scheme of things i don't
think it matters too much and the knight
is arguably a little bit out of play
which is why of course knight c4 was
played
and in this position i went for
have a strange looking move but there is
a common positional maneuver especially
for this structure
is that this knight is generally best
placed on d3
and the way to get there or one way to
get there is via e1
so i play 91 looks very strange
but it's not necessarily about
where i am currently it's about where
i'm going and i want to get to d3 where
the knight will be even more centralized
and also hold on to the b2 pawn
so opponent plays queen b6
i defend the b-pawn
and now knight a5 back i should explain
here uh my opponent set up a sneaky trap
if i play knight d3 too soon then
there's knight b3
forking the rook
and hitting the pawn
and then wherever the work moves
knight takes d4 is a pork
combining the pin
and the fork and i'd be losing material
here so rook a3
i'm doing even more contortions
uh looks like my pieces
uh it reminds me of a contortionist
trying to fit inside like a small box
but uh
very soon i i end up untangling
uh first with knight d3 uh then queen d1
i wanted to get the queen eventually to
the king side
queen d6 i move my rook back
and even though it seems like i've spent
a lot of time just kind of dancing
around
i am making steady improvements because
now the queen is ready to come in and
these pieces they look nice but what are
they actually doing the structure along
with the knight is super super solid
queen d8 queen f3
now i should note um
maybe a little bit before this point i'm
sure people have noticed the timestamps
are no longer here
all the
games in the lee chess broadcast just
stopped transmitting moves so
unfortunately we don't have the time
stamps but i do have the full game and
that's what matters and i do vaguely
remember the time situation
my opponent was already getting like
really low on time
probably below 10 minutes at this point
and i still had over 30 minutes
so time was was very nice but the
position is still very much a fight
queen g5 played i improve my rooks
and after queen f5 i did not want to
trade queens
i'm i'm definitely playing for more
than just an equal end game so i play
queen e3
rookie 7
and yeah at this point my opponent i
think was already below a minute
like so much time was spent in the
middle game uh from my opponent like
just trying to figure out what to do
and i was feeling really really good
here
uh played rook to d1
the point being i'm over defining the
knight so my queen is not completely
tied down
and i had a cool idea with rook d1 which
we're going to see very soon
is after queen e4 queen d2 knight c4
counter-attacking my queen so again kind
of offering a queen trade but i don't
want to trade queens i play queen e1
queen h4
and now i play knight b4
and i was really happy to come up with
this idea because this is a
multi-purpose move
not only do i have the simple threat of
taking on d5 exploiting the pinned
e-pawn
but i'm also preparing the rook lift and
this was one reason for rook t1 earlier
is to eventually get the rook to align
with black's king
so my opponent um around this point my
opponent was playing almost every move
with less than 10 seconds left
now there was a 30 second increment so
he was basically living on increment
but i tried to keep the tempo played
rook d3
queen d8 and rook g3
so gradually making progress
the rook has found its way to g3
and now this is probably a good time to
advertise
my merch i do have a new design
and uh yeah you can get your do you even
rook lift bro tank top
at merch.iamrosen.com
and show off your amazing
muscular rook and maybe show off your
guns as well
but let's get back to the game
i did execute the the beautiful rook
lift now i wasn't wearing the
rook lift tank top during the game but
maybe i should have been as a nice
moment to be showing off my muscular
rook
but anyway the game continued knight d6
and i
re-positioned my knight back into the
center knight at 5 rook f3
and queen g5
so
the pressure is gradually building up i
play rook to f4 and this is actually yet
another rook lift because black is
controlling the g3 square i wanted to
eventually play rook g4 and very soon i
was able to accomplish that
f3 defending the maid threat opening up
the queen and preparing rook g4 uh this
is a nice multi-purpose move
and here black has really nothing better
than to just retreat
after which i play rook g4 queen f6
and now h4
and yeah my opponent was still very low
on time i probably had like 10 to 15
minutes at this point
and queen d8 was played
with my opponent having just over 30
seconds left on the clock
so in this position i realized it's a
critical moment
because there is potential to sacrifice
and transform the position entirely
and the key move i was calculating is
rook takes e6
and it's a move that looks
very promising at first
but
it requires also concrete calculation so
i spent about maybe four or five minutes
before
taking on e6 i decided that
now's the time to to go all in and after
takes takes
rook to f7 what i initially calculated
is that i can just take with a rook and
prepare knight e5 and i have two pawns
for the exchange and it should be very
very good for black because the queen
is tied down to the rook on c8 and i
went ahead and played rook takes g6
but i completely overlooked black's next
move
rook c6
and i think just because my point was so
low on time and i was trying to use the
clock as a weapon
i was also just tired given it was the
final round
the morning round this move completely
escaped me
and i realized that
uh-oh black is simplifying and after i
move my queen
takes takes my h-pawn hangs
and now it's not so clear if i can even
play for win
and there's even the risk of being worse
here
now one move i i can still play is 95
but this would just walk into perpetual
check
maybe black could even play some rook f6
as well
so i didn't go for 95 but
i went for queen to e6 i was still
trying to play for a win threatening to
take the pawn on d5 so black retreats to
e7
and this was a very nice move for black
because now if i take on d5 i'm losing
the knight after queen to e3 if i block
with the knight there's queen e1 and
this is losing for white
so i had seen a scene i can't take on d5
and i played the move that i thought
still gave me some winning chances it's
queen e5 but at this point we're both
getting really low on time and after
takes takes
i'm still down the exchange i only have
a pawn for it
and things are simplifying quickly
um and they've actually simplified in
black's favor
given that now the rook is ready to come
in to c4
and
i might already be just much worse here
realizing that there's not a great way
to cover all the pawns on the queen side
also the king is ready to come in
so i decided to play king f2 and the
move i was scared of here is rook to c4
after which i think black is winning a
pawn if i play a5 there's rook a4
um
and if we went into this i was going to
play king e3 takes and king d4
but
i'm pretty sure black is the only one
that can win this position
given that uh i no longer even have a
pawn for the exchange and very soon like
if i ever play b4 there's gonna be rook
a2
and the king is still ready to come in
maybe in combination with
the kingside pawns rolling
but we didn't go into this
instead my opponent played king f7
which i think is also a very fine move
and then i played king to e3
and i decided to offer a draw here
realizing that
it's very very difficult to still play
for a win and i'm probably
about to meet much worse
and i was not expecting my opponent to
take the draw and he started thinking
for um
it's almost a whole remainder of his
time and he had like 40 seconds left he
got down to 12 seconds
and then he paused the clock and
accepted my draw offer
and that was a game
uh somewhat unexpected finish
at some moment in the game i thought i
was going to be pretty easily winning
and then
the final position i think i was very
close to just being lost
so
i i think a draw is a fair result
i'm not entirely sure how to feel about
this game
um but i guess i can't complain too much
given that i could have easily lost it
and kudos to my opponent for
fighting very well with just such low
time
in the later stages of the game
so
um that's the tournament tournament's
over i finished with four out of nine
i think overall it was uh
it was a normal result maybe i lost like
a couple rating points
but that's not really why
i'm competing i don't really care too
much about rating i think i had a lot of
fun interesting instructive games
i want to give a big thanks to those of
you who've been watching the recaps and
offering your comments and feedback and
questions
it's been super fun to play the
tournament in abu dhabi the conditions
were amazing hotel was nice
everyone who i've met here was very nice
as well
and i'd love to return for uh for next
year if possible
i could probably talk a lot more about
various things over the event maybe i'll
make like one final
uh conclusion video
but um
i'm tired and uh i have not
streamed live in uh
in over a week since before the
tournament began
so if you're watching this on youtube be
sure to check out my twitch channel it's
very possible that if you're watching
this
sometime in the future
i might be live in the present moment
at least your present moment so anyway
thanks again
and stay tuned for more maybe slightly
different youtube content
in the near future goodbye